14 superhéroes se reúnen en secreto en
la luna tres de ellos resultan ser
villanos disfrazados cuántos de ellos
son superhéroes reales pongan pausa en
el vídeo para intentar resolverlos por
su cuenta ya que lo intentaron por su
cuenta vamos a resolverlo paso a paso
14 superhéroes se reúnen en la luna de
esos 14 nos dicen que tres eran villanos
disfrazados así que de los 14 estamos
tratando con alguno de los tres villanos
o con los verdaderos superhéroes
una forma de ver esto es que el 14 está
compuesto por villanos y por superhéroes
reales estos signos de interrogación son
los superhéroes reales que tenemos que
encontrar esta relación puede escribirse
de varias maneras una de ellas podría
ser tres más nuestra interrogación de
los superhéroes reales y esto será igual
a 14 el número total de personajes que
están en la luna
otra forma de escribirlos es que tenemos
14 menos 3 igual a nuestra interrogación
podemos ver que la figura indica que 14
está compuesto de 3 y nuestra
interrogación por lo que si tomamos 14
menos 3 nos darán la interrogación el
número de superhéroes reales cuánto es
14 menos 3 a de varias formas de
resolverlo una de ellas es bueno 14
menos uno es 13 13 menos uno es 12 12
menos 1 es 11 así que nos queda que 11
es igual a nuestra interrogación por lo
que tenemos 11 superhéroes reales vamos
a resolver otro problema encontramos
muchos monstruos en un lago cercano
nueve de ellos tienen rayas y cinco de
ellos tienen manchas
cuántos monstruos hay en el lago que nos
está diciendo
y este es el número total de monstruos
en el lago que queremos encontrar y nos
dicen que 9 tienen rayas y 5 tienen
manchas el total de los monstruos serán
los 9 que tienen rayas más los cinco que
tienen manchas 9 5 y buena nuestra
interrogación
cuánto es 95 quizás ya me aprendí que es
14 si no sumó 91 igual a 10 10 más uno
igual a 11 11 más uno igual a 12 doce
más uno igual a 13 y 13 más uno igual a
14 14 es igual a nuestra interrogación
cuántos monstruos hay 14